WELL WE'LL GET STARTED RIGHT ON
TIME AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND WILL HAVE -- PRESENTING OUR
FIRST BILL THE CENTER GLAZER.
AND WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
ONE TWO MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S
OKAY IF I START WITH SB.
EIGHT FANTASTIC.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS -- ISN'T AS MANY OF
YOU REMEMBER I PRESENTED A
SIMILAR BILL TO THIS COMMITTEE.
WOULD BAN SMOKING AT STATE PARKS
AND BEACHES THAT UNFORTUNATELY
AFTER PASSING THE LEGISLATURE BY
A WIDE MARGIN.
THE BILL WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN FOR A SECOND TIME.
SO I'M I'M HOPING THAT TO THE
THIRD TIME'S THE CHARM.
I HAVE HAD THIS LEGISLATION.
BUT THE SB EIGHT WOULD PROHIBITS
POKING AT UNIT AT THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM.
AND MAKE IT INTO AN FOR
INFRACTION PUNISHABLE BY A FINE
OF UP TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THE SMOKING PROHIBITION
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL WOULD BE
ENFORCED ONLY AFTER SIGNS HAVE
BEEN POSTED.
THE BILL ALSO ALSO AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. TO DESIGNATE AREAS
AS EXEMPT FROM THE SMOKING
PROHIBITION.
RECORDED THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION TOBACCO KILLS OVER
FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EVERY YEAR.
SECONDS THOUSANDS MORE AND COST
THE STATE MORE THAN TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION AND HEALTH CARE MEDICAID
AND LOST PRODUCTIVITY.
ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
SMOKING AND HEALTH CARE COSTS
THE STATE ARE WELL KNOWN BUT
SMOKING ALSO HARMS THE
ENVIRONMENT IN SIGNIFICANT WAYS.
CIGARETTE BUT THROUGH A MAJOR
SOURCE OF WASTE AND LETTER.
CIGARETTES ALSO BECAUSE WILD
FIRES.
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED FIRES HAVE BEEN CAUSED
BY SMOKING FOUR HUNDRED FIRES
CAUSED BY SMOKING SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN BANNING
SMOKING AT STATE PARKS IS THE
NEXT STEP IN ADDRESSING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED WITH
SMOKING.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY FOR THIS
LEGISLATION I HAVE SO WHAT THIS
IS HERE IN SUPPORT -- BRANDON
DAWSON FROM THE SIERRA CLUB.
AND I AM A FEES HERE YET BUT WE
KILL MASTRO D'AMATO AS YOU'RE
FROM THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
GOOD MORNING BRENNAN DAWSON WAS
HERE CO CALIFORNIA -- FIRST OF
ANYTHING SENATOR GLAZER FOR
PURSUING THIS POLICY OF THE LAST
FEW YEARS -- IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT NOT JUST FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO A
MARMON A PERSPECTIVE THE FACTS
ARE WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
THE CIGARETTE **** CONTAIN OVER
A HUNDRED FIFTY TOXIC CHEMICALS
THAT ONCE DISCARDED ARE CONSUMED
BY WILDLIFE BOTH FISH AND BIRDS --
AND THEY CAN EVEN LEACH INTO THE
WATER SUPPLY AND TAKE THE WATER
QUALITY THAT BOTH HUMANS AND
ANIMALS CONSUME.
THEY POSE OVER 20% OF THE WASTE
FOUND IN OUR STATE PARKS AND AS
MENTIONED THERE ARE BECAUSE OF
WILDFIRES WITH SUBS COULD AFFECT.
BOTH OUR NATURAL LANDS AND OUR
ECONOMY HERE IN THIS BEAUTIFUL
STATE OF WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOW BUT
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR THE BILL.
MY NAME IS THE CHAIR MEMBERS
JUST MALANA BEHOFF OF THREE
GROUPS A HEALTH GROUP THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH ASSOCIATION
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE DO RECOGNIZE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN ONGOING CONCERNS
A SMOKING.
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
HILL THE BAY AND THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBY COALITION THANK YOU BOTH
OF BRING THIS BILL TO US.
WE ARE JOB OUT.
MR TURN MEMBERS THE SOLOMON
COLORS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND ON GOING SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THERE
BUT ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ZACHARY COR OVER
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE GIVENS OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE THE STATE
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEWMAN WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THEM.
I SEE NO ONE AND QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
COMMENTS QUITE.
THANK YOU CHAIR IN THE THANK YOU
SENATOR.
I THOUGHT THAT I DEALT WITH THIS
SO ISSUE -- LAST YEAR -- TO BUT
THE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S OF THE
TOLD.
SO HERE THIS IS AS A SAYS SECOND
THE IDENTICAL PO -- I THINK I
STATED THAT THOUGHT.
NOW DESPITE THE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS I SEE -- TO
OPPOSE OF FROM ON THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS A MY POSITION IS THAT --
I AM VERY -- STRONG.
IN I'M AND BANNING SMOKING IN
THE PUBLIC PLACES.
NOT TO MINIMIZE SO THE SMOKE WAS
RIGHTS HOWEVER.
IF YOU.
LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF OF THE
SMALL COASTAL PERCENTAGE.
I WOULD TO SAY THAT THE NON
SPOKE WAS UP -- OVERWHELMING
NEED MORE.
HOWEVER OF FEW WHO MAY CHOOSE.
TO A SMALL IN THE PUBLIC AREAS.
WHAT IMPACT THE REST OF THE?
POPULATION IN THAT AREA.
AND SECONDARY -- IMPACT.
NEGATIVE IMPACT UPON HEALTH THE
HOUSE.
HAS BEEN FOND.
OF SOMETIMES -- IF AND MORE
DANGEROUS THAN US MORE QUOTE IS
SELF.
FOR AND THAT THAT STUDY WAS --
CONDUCTED BY MY INTERN SO WHEN
SO.
CONCERT MEMBER OR A BELIEVE.
NIGHT THE CITY OF IRVINE.
AND DAY WAS SO OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE THAT THE HARMFUL
EFFECTS OF TO SECONDARY SMOKE.
SO -- FROM THEIR STUDY.
THE MADE A RECOMMENDATION THAT
THEN THE CITY OF IRVINE IN THE
PUBLIC [inaudible]
SPACE.
IT'S A SMOKING.
WOULD BE BANNED AND THAT HAS
EVER SINCE THEN IT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED.
AND EVERYONE IS HAPPY.
AND THE STATE THE BEACH PARKS ON
NO DIFFERENCES AND IF THE
SMOKERS SO DO -- CARE SOME
CONSIDERATION FOR NON SMOKERS
AND ON MANY TIMES.
A YOU'D FIND THE THE SECRET BUT
AND VERY CLEAN EVAN CORRIDORS SO
BEACHES AND THEN WHATEVER AMEND
THAT DOT TESSA -- IN
INCONSIDERATE THAT ACCESS OF A
FEW BAD.
THE SMOKERS ARE SO I THINK OF
THIS ARE NON.
SMOKING BAN.
IN THE PUBLIC BEACHES SO.
IS -- E. INCLUDING IS SEPARATE I
THINK THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING -- UNTIL YOU CONVINCE SO
THE OPPONENTS I THINK WE SHOULD.
TRY AND ON OUR BEHALF TO SUPPORT
TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
COMMENTS COMMENTS QUESTIONS ALL
RIGHT IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE
THIS BILL AND WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM AND ON A COMMOTION.
LOOK AT WHAT THE MOTION WE GET A
QUORUM.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU -- CLOSING COMMENTS IN
CLOSING I JUST WANT TO THANK
THAT -- MICHAEL AUTHOR THAT
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
FOR JOINING ME IN THIS EFFORT
THE LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR AND
HOPEFULLY WITH THE NEW GOVERNOR
THAT -- WILL HAVE A SYMPATHETIC
EAR -- TO THE IMPORTANCEOF THIS
BILL OF THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU YEAH WHICH I
SENT TO YOUR SECOND BILL.
YEAH SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN OKAY THIS IS
THAT THIS IS SENATE BILL. SEVEN
SIX SEVEN AND I AM NOT PLEASED
TO BE JOINED BY ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES -- CO AUTHOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN REBEKAH POWER QUE
HAN I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND I KNOW SHE'S GOING TO ADD TO
MY REMARKS IN JUST A MOMENT.
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC.
THIS CELEBRATION OF THE CARNEGIE
STATE VEHICLE RECREATION AREA
ALSO KNOWN AS THE ALAMEDA TEST
TEST Là EXPANSION. FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES.
BUT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
WORK ONLY IF IF THE DEPARTMENT
DETERMINES IT'S IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST DATA REQUIREMENTS.
IT PROVIDES AN OPTION.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A PLAN
TO EXPAND CARNEGIE -- SB ARE A
EXPANSION PLAN FOR RECREATIONAL
USE WAS APPROVED.
WHICH LED TO BROAD LOCAL
OPPOSITION.
THE PROJECT IS CURRENTLY IN
LITIGATION INCLUDING THE THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA CHALLENGING
THE SEQUEL APPROVALS.
A LARGE DELEGATION OF BAY AREA
CAUCUS MEMBERS AND I HAVE SINCE
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT TO CONSIDER
SELLING THIS EXPANSION AREA.
RECOUPING THE FUNDS -- FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE USE.
AND OF THE VESTING FROM A
SITUATION THAT'S BEEN MILD MIRED
IN CONTROVERSY. FOR FOR ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS THAT THAT EVEN
IF THEY WANTED TO SELL THE LAND.
WE WOULD BE LEGISLATION TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
WHICH IS WHY I AM HERE TODAY IN
THIS BILL IS BEFORE YOU TODAY.
THIS MEASURES SUPPORTED BY A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS IN AGENCIES --
WE'RE GONNA BE JOINED BY SOME OF
MY FRIENDS IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY AND IT SPEAKS TO THE
PRISTINE LAND -- WITH GREAT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECOLOGICAL
ATTRIBUTES THAT AS THAT IS AT
STAKE IN THIS LOCAL ISSUE THAT
WE'RE HERE TO TALK WITH YOU
ABOUT AND I WANT.
TO AGAIN THANK AND ENERGY IS
SOMEONE YOU KNOW WELL MICHAEL
Là THROUGH THE BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
THIS MORNING -- SO YEAH I'M HERE
JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE STAR DISTRICT IT'S A CRUCIAL
WILDLIFE QUARTER CONNECTING TO
MOUNT DIABLO THE DISTRICT HAS
BEEN INTERESTED IN.
PRESERVING AND SO THERE'S AN
INTEREST IN ALLOWING THE PARTS
THAT THEY FIND IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST TO CONSERVE THIS LAND --
THERE IS A NEIGHBORING PARK THAT
WILL NOT BE TOUCH THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT THERE IS
AN EXISTING OFFERED VEHICLE
PARKED THAT WON'T BE AFFECTED BY
THIS LEGISLATION OR ANY ACTIONS
THERE OF BUT THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO THE DISTRICT TO REALLY.
PROTECT A CRUCIAL WILDLIFE
CORRIDOR IN LAND IT'S REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT OUR COMMUNITY
AND SO WE HOPE THAT YOU'LL
SUPPORT US AND GIVING US THE
ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
PROJECT IF IT'S IN THE INTEREST
OF THE COMMUNITY IN THE PUBLIC.
I THANK YOU.
WHEN IS THIS?
YES THE THE MORNING OF RAIN AND
ALSO SEE OUR COMPANY AGAIN --
CYNICAL CALIFORNIA'S MORE THAN
FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS AROUND THE STATE BUT
A MORE ARE BUT ONE OF OUR
LARGEST CHAPTERS INCLUDES --
BEAR CHAPTER WHERE THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY TESTING PARK EXPANSIONARY
IS LOCATED AND THEY'VE BEEN A
PART OF THAT PROGRAM FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE FOR
C. I. R. TEMPT WAS -- INSTITUTED
WE'RE HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR YES
SO ON AT SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN AS
WRITTEN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SCIENTISTS CONSENSUS STATEMENT
ON THE ECOLOGICAL BY THE STATE
PARKS ALAMEDA TOUGHLY EXPANSION
AREA.
SIGNED BY OVER FORTY FIVE
SCIENTISTS INCLUDING NUMEROUS
UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS AND
RESEARCHERS THAT STATE WHY SB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN IS NEEDED.
THERE'S AN OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
AT THE STATE PARKS OWNED ALAMEDA
TEXAS PENSION AREA.
ALSO REFERRED TO AS TUSSLE HAS
WHERE ECOLOGICAL VALUE IN
CONTAINS AN ABUNDANCE OF HIGHLY
SENSITIVE NOT RESOURCES AND
THERE'S A LONG ESTABLISHED BODY
OF PEER REVIEWED STUDIES.
THAT SHOW THE RECREATIONAL OFF
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE USE BECAUSE
IT REPERTOIRE DAMAGES TO SOILS
VEGETATION AND WILDLIFE.
TESS WAS BIOLOGICAL IMPORTANCE
IS IRREFUTABLE ITS LOCATION AT
THE INTERSECTION OF BIOTIC ZONES
RESULT IN RARE BIODIVERSITY AND
SERVED AS A SPECIES SAVING
CORRIDORS EMBARK BUFFERS IN
TIMES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA'S EARLIEST
NATIONALIST INCLUDING JOSEPH
GRINNELL AND JOHN YOUR FATHER
THIS YEAR CLUB AND BOTHER THE
NATIONAL PARK SYSTEM --
RECOGNIZE THE HIGH CONSERVATION
VALUE OF THE AREA WHERE TEST
WERE TESTED WAS SITUATED.
AND TESLA HOLDS FORTY TWO
SPECIAL STATUS WILDLIFE SPECIES
INCLUDING EIGHT FEDERALLY OR
STATE OWNED STATE LISTED IN
CANDIDATES SPECIES THIRTEEN
SPECIAL STATUS AND TWENTY EIGHT
LOCALLY RARE PLANT SPECIES.
AND SEVEN SENSITIVE VEGETATION
COMMUNITIES.
THE BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IS
MATCHED BY SIGNIFICANT CULTURAL
VALUES INCLUDING NEGATIVE
CALIFORNIANS SITES OF
ARCHAEOLOGICAL SPIRITUAL AND
CEREMONIAL IMPORTANCE.
AND HISTORICAL TOWN SITE IN COAL
MINE OF TESLA AND OTHER YOU
EUROPEANS OTHER ERA HISTORICAL
SITES.
THE SENSITIVE RARE NATURAL
CULTURAS RESOURCES AND COVER
NEARLY AN ENTIRE TEAM OF TESTED
LANDSCAPE.
LAYER UPON LAYER OF AREAS THAT
MUST BE PROTECTED WITH NO
DAMAGING -- H. B. RECREATION USE
WE CANNOT SPLIT THE BABY OF TEST
WITHOUT DESTROYING ITS UNITS
NUMEROUS AIR PLACE WILL
BIOLOGICAL CULTURAL VALUES.
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN PROVIDE THE
SOUND MECHANISM TO MEET OUR
COLLECTIVE PUBLIC DUTY TO
PROTECT TEST WAS BY
EXTRAORDINARY BIOLOGICAL CULTURE
RESOURCES IN A PROBABLY RETURN
CELLS PROVIDE REFER SEEDS GO TO
THE H. M. V. R..
DIVISION OF THE PARKS DEPARTMENT.
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN PROVIDE THE
WISE USE A WIDE A FAIR WAY TO
RESOLVE THIS TWENTY YEAR
CONTROVERSY IN A MANNER THAT IS
GOOD FOR PARKS -- EACH OF WHICH
ENVIAR DIVISION STATE LOCAL
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
HI.
OKAY YEAH GOOD MORNING CARE
BECAUSE MY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
NANCY ROTARY.
YEAH I'M NANCY RODRIGUEZ AND
WITHOUT FRIENDS ATTESA PARK
HEALTH ONE OF THE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND GROUPS IN
ALLIANCE TO PRESERVE THE SPECIAL
PLACE.
SO I WANT TO MENTION SOME ITEMS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ADDRESSED
TODAY.
AND I'LL PROBABLY DO THESE HOOPS
MORALIST FAR FORM.
SO -- THE FIRST ONE IS
PRESERVATION OF THE ALAMEDA
TESLA EXPANSION AREA IT'S A
LOCAL PRIORITY.
AND SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN IS A
DISTRICT MEASURE.
ALL OF THE ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSE
SUSPENSION AREA ALSO KNOWN AS
TESSLER TESLA PARK.
IS LOCATED IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN DOES NOT
ESTABLISH ANY STATEWIDE
PRESIDENT IT ADDRESSES A
SPECIFIC.
LOCAL TWENTY YEAR CONTROVERSY
THAT RECOGNIZES THE O. H. P.
RECREATION CAN BE LOCATE FADED
ALL SWEAR WHILE TESLA'S DIVERSE
ECO SYSTEM.
CANNOT BE MOVED.
THERE'S OVERWHELMING LOCAL
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND THIS
INCLUDES NOT JUST COMMUNITY
GROUPS BUT ALSO LOCAL AGENCIES.
SUCH AS THE ALAMEDA COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA THE CITY OF LIVER.
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
ANOTHER AND OTHERS.
PUBLIC NOTICE ABOUT THE CARNEGIE
ALWAYS BE EXPANSION PLANS
OCCURRED AFTER THE LAND WAS
ALREADY PURCHASED IN.
TWO THOUSAND WHAT THAT WAS WHEN
THE FIRST E. I. R. WAS COMPLETED.
THERE WAS NO -- ACQUISITION THE
I. R. PRIOR TO THE PURCHASE.
SB TWO FORTY NINE DID NOT
ADDRESS TESSLER PRESERVATION.
SCIENCE CONFIRMS THAT OHB USES
DAMAGING.
CARNEGIE I THINK AS AS YOU
ALREADY MENTIONED IN SOME DETAIL.
KIND OF THE S. V. R. A.
ATTENDANCE HAS DECREASED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHILE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
THE EAST BAY AND THE STATE
SURVEYS THE PUBLIC PRIORITY AND
DEMAND IT'S FOR OPEN SPACE AND
NATURE AREAS.
MEMORANDUM IN RUPP DO REAL QUICK
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
PARDON I'M GOING TO INTERRUPT
YOU SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
FLORA.
RIGHT WE CALL THE ROLL.
IT WATER GARCIA RESIDENCE.
GALLAGHER BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible] TO FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
YEAH GLORIA.
KALRA LEVINE BLANCA RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS WOOD [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
SO IN CONCLUSION.
SOME OF THE BEST MOVES FORWARD
LINKING WORK OF OUR STATE HAS
RESULTED IN THE PRESERVATION OF
THE NATURAL WONDERS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE FUTURE.
THE ECOLOGICAL INTEGRITY RICH
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
HISTORIC RELEVANCE OF TESLA ARE
TOO IMPORTANT A SACRIFICE THAT
WAS A QUOTE FROM THE FORTY FIVE
PLUS SCIENTISTS THAT YOU
MENTIONED.
SO X. SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX SEVEN
PROVIDES A WAY TO MEET OUR
COLLECTIVE DUTY TO PROTECT US
WELL.
IN A WAY THAT IS WISE AND FAIR.
WE ASK FOR YOUR YES VOTE ON SB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN AS WRITTEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IT'S GOING FORWARD STATE NAME
ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS UP IN SUPPORT OF THAT
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LUCAS FRERICHS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TAMERA ROYCE ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF OPEN SPACE AND
VINEYARDS A STRONG SUPPORT.
PRESSMAN YANNI ON BEHALF OF THE
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT.
I'M DAVID FREEZE CONSERVATION
CHAIR OF SAN JOAQUIN AUDUBON OF
SAN JOAQUIN OTHER BARDS PRESS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN. ONE PUBLIC ALLOW
NINETIES MANAGER FOR SAID ABOUT
DOUBLE ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE
THAN A THOUSAND MEASURE --
MEMBERS WE STATE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU.
BOB HERTZBERG OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY OCT
REPRESENTING SEEIN PS EAST BAY
CHAPTER AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE GRASSLANDS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
WRITTEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAPTAIN PRESS I AM
CHAIRPERSON OF THE NORTHERN
VALLEY OAK BAY MIWOK ALONI TRIBE.
OUR MEMBERS ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE SENATE BILL SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTINE CORRAL NORTHERN
VALLEY -- GOOD IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL BARONE BRIDGE TO
PROFESSIONAL ARCHAEOLOGIST HERE
SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN NEED ESCALANTE
REPRESENTING ALONI AUDUBON
SOCIETY AND STRONG SUPPORT AS
WRITTEN.
CARLA MAIL CASTRO VALLEY
POLITICAL HOW HURDLE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DONNA BALL REPRESENTING CITIZENS
COMMITTEE TO COMPLETE THE REFUGE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER SPENCE
TIMER PRESENTING THE SOCIETY OF
AMERICAN INDIANS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB -- SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN AND AS ALL NATIVE
AMERICAN GROUPS THAT'S DOCUMENT
AND HAVE DOCUMENTED WE ARE ARE
ARE ASKING THAT THERE BE NO --
H. FI RECREATIONAL USE
WHATSOEVER ON THE LAND TO
PRESERVE THE ANCIENT ARTIFACTS
SACRED SITES BURIAL THANKS AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST
YOUR NAME -- ORGANIZATION THIS
IS ALL -- IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANKS I'M DAVID FIRST TIME THE
OUR ELECTED DIRECTOR AND CHAIR
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
LIVERMORE AREA RECREATION PARK
DISTRICT.
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICT OUR
BOARD OF FIVE DIRECTORS.
I UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
FAYE YOUNGER OF LIVERMORE I
REPRESENT FRIENDS OF LIVER MORE
IN STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DAVID LAWN OF NEVER MORE.
REPRESENTING LIVERMORE HERITAGE
GILDON TRI VALLEY TRAILBLAZERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
ARTHUR HOLE FRIENDS OF THE
ARROYO AT LIVERMORE HILL HIKERS
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I MARYLAND CESAR RUSSELL IVING
IN EAST ALAMEDA COUNTY.
I'M ON THE BOARD OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
WHICH SUBMITTED A LETTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN HOWEVER TODAY
I'M REPRESENTING TO OTHER GROUPS
THE TEST THE ROAD RESIDENTS
ALLIANCE WHERE I LIVE YOU NAME
AN ORGANIZATION AND IN
SUPPORTERS YES TED AT NAY
SUBMITTED A LETTER TESSLER ROAD
RESIDENTS ALLIANCE AS WELL AS
EAST ALAMEDA COUNTY RESIDENTS.
I'M SORRY EAST ALAMEDA COUNTY
RANCHERS ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN ASKED
WRITTEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CELESTIA MINDY
REPRESENTING MOUNT DIABLO
AUDUBON SOCIETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
HI ASK UP FOLKS -- WISHING TO
GIVE TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
THIS CALL FOR STUFF YOU GUYS
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
TERRY MCHALE OVER THERE AND READ
AND ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
COALITION OF OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE --
RECREATION STE.
THIS THIS IS A CONTROVERSY THAT
THE AUTHORS CRACK FOR TWENTY
YEARS WE'VE HAD THIS DISCUSSION.
AND IT'S LIKELY THAT WE WILL
DISCUSS IT FOR ANOTHER TWENTY
YEARS WE DON'T DO SOMETHING.
AND SO WHILE WE'RE VERY
RESPECTFUL OF WHAT THE AUTHORS
PROPOSED.
WE OPPOSE IT FOR ONE SIMPLE
REASON.
WE BELIEVE LAST YEAR THIS
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE WE
SPENT AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
TIME.
WORKING ON A BILL THAT.
UPDATED OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION THERE ARE EIGHT OF
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PARKS
WE HAVE MORE SCIENTISTS WORKING
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION
IN THE OTHER.
WE SPEND MORE TIME PROTECTING
CULTURAL AND NATURAL RESOURCES
THAN ANY OTHER -- IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE IN TESLA WE
HAVE SPENT MORE TIME THAN ANY
OTHER MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS A
LEGITIMATE PLACE FOR OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE RECREATION.
HOWEVER THERE IS EXTRAORDINARY
LOCAL OPPOSITION.
AND IT WILL LIKELY CONTINUE.
AND AS LONG AS MR GLAZERS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND AS LONG AS I'M
ALIVE WE WILL PROBABLY HAVE A
BILL LIKE THIS INTRODUCED UNTIL
THERE IS RESOLUTION.
OUR PROBLEM WITH THE BILL IS
THAT THERE IS THE IDEA.
THAT WE WILL HAVE A HEARING AND
THAT THE STATE PARKS WILL CHANGE
THEIR MIND.
AND SUDDENLY TURN OVER THIS
PLACE THAT IS SET ASIDE FOR OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION AND
TURN IT OVER TO THE LOCALS.
MY BELIEF IS IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT HEARING.
THEN THERE SHOULD ALSO BE A
CONSEQUENCE FOR THOSE THAT MR
GLAZER SENATOR GLAZER REPRESENTS.
THE IDEA THAT WE DO THIS HEARING
AND IF IT TURNS OUT THAT PARKS
IS DONE EVERYTHING THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEN WE QUICKLY.
PUT IN THE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
RECREATION ACTIVITY AS IT WAS
PROPOSED TO DO THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD.
THAT WE NOT HAVE THIS HEARING IN
THIS DISCUSSION EVERY SINGLE
YEAR.
BOB I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING I DO
APPRECIATE SENATOR GLAZERS
OFFICE IN HIM PERSONALLY. FOR
HIS WILLINGNESS TO TALK TO US
AND I ASKED FOR A NO VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
I'M ANY GRANTED ON BEHALF OF THE
OFF ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION -- I AM JUST AN OFF
ROADER.
AND THIS IS THE THIRD YEAR IN A
ROW THAT I FIND MYSELF IN THE
POSITION OF HAVING TO DEFEND.
THE FORM OF RECREATION THAT I
LOVE IS THIS.
BILL IS TARGETED DIRECTLY AT ME
AND BY EXTENSION THOSE THAT I
REPRESENT.
FRANKLY WE DON'T UNDERSTAND IT
WE'RE ALREADY.
OF PROTECTING THE RESOURCE AND
ALL THE MENTION OF THE PRISTINE
NATURE IS BECAUSE ALL THE WORK
THE PARK IS PUT INTO IT FOR THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS [inaudible]
BESIDES THAT.
WE OWE IT SHOULD BE OUR DIVISION
OF STATE PARKS ALREADY HAS THE
HIGHEST LEGISLATIVE MANDATE
HIGHER THAN ANY PRIVATE ENTITY
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER STATE PARK.
TO PRESERVE NATURAL AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES WE ARE HOLD LITTER OF
HELD LITERALLY TO A HIGHER
AUTHORITY [inaudible]
IN.
SO IT'S WITH FRUSTRATION THAT WE
ASK YOU TODAY -- TO FOR NO VOTE.
WE DO AGREE WITH MR MCHALE THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE.
THAT ONCE STARTED ONCE THIS
LITTLE TOLL HOLD IS ACHIEVED --
IT WILL GO AGAINST EXISTING PARK
IT WILL THEN GO FURTHER DOWN THE
STATE AND BEFORE WE KNOW WHAT WE
WILL HAVE EVERY STATE PARK.
EVERY THAT CATERS TO WHICH WE
ARE CREATION TARGETED BECAUSE
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKE IN
FAVOR HAVE ALREADY DONE THAT.
THEY HAVE ALREADY.
TARGETED US BECAUSE THEY DON'T
LIKE OUR FORM OF RECREATION --
IN REALITY WE'RE JUST SORT IN
NORMAL PEOPLE WHO LIKE GOING OUT
WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND HAVING A
GOOD TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN CAPPING
LUNCH REPRESENTING THE OFFER
REAL VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION AND I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THIS BILL FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED AND WE TO WORKED
ON LEGISLATION -- WITH SENATOR
ALLEN IN THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
PAST YEAR THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE.
BRING BACK TO DIS ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
A QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SEEN
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN A COUPLE THINGS IN
CLARIFICATION -- THE REFERENCE
TO LEGISLATION AND AND THE PASS
WAS THAT'S BE TWO FORTY NINE BY
ALLEN WHICH EXTENDED THE EIICHI
PROGRAM.
NOTHING IN THIS LEGISLATION
INTERFERES WITH THAT -- OVERALL
POLICY FRAMEWORK THAT YOU
APPROVED IN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED.
THIS BILL ONLY PROVIDES AN
OPTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND REC ONLY AN OPTION. TO
BE CLEAR WE HAVE AN OFF ROAD
HIGHWAY VEHICLE PARKED RIGHT
THERE NEXT DOOR THIS PROPERTY
IT'S IN OUR DISTRICT.
YEAH IT'S ACTIVELY USED ALTHOUGH.
THE ACTIVITY HAS GONE DOWN.
BUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
THAT MEANS TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
THERE'S A PICTURE OF THE THE
CARD HE PROPERTY AND TEN WHAT
OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE USE DOES TO
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT HAS A LOT
OF IMPACTS OKAY.
AND SO THAT'S EXISTING USE --
NEXT DOOR TO THIS PROPERTY.
AND AND THIS IS THE A PICTURE OF
THE PROPERTY THAT WE'RE TRYING.
TO GIVE THE OPTION OPTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT TO PRESERVE IF THEY
CAN'T WORK OUT THERE OFF HIGHWAY
EXPANSION IN THIS SPACE DOESN'T
INTERFERE WITH THEIR EXPANSION
pIT'S IN THE COURTS IS GOING TO
BE THERE FOR A LONG TIME THEY'RE
GONNA SPEND MILLIONS DEFENDING
IT WE WANT TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT AN OPTION.
THAT THEY SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
THEY CAN GET ALL THEIR MONEY
BACK THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT NOT
TO THE ANDS BE GIVEN AWAY THEY
HAVE TO BE HAS TO BE SOLD.
AND AT A MINIMUM THEY HAVE TO
GET ALL THEIR MONEY BACK -- THAT
CAN GO INTO THAT FINE FOR OTHER
OFF HIGHWAY USE IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE OR EVEN IN OUR AREA
BUT THERE'S A PROCESS FOR THAT --
FINALLY I WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO
THE MANY PEOPLE WHO TRAVELED
HERE FROM FAR AND WIDE TO BE A
PART OF THIS YEAR HEARING MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M SORRY IT TOOK SO
LONG -- BUT THERE IS A LOT OF
PASSION LOCALLY THAT'S WHY WE'RE
HERE. TO GIVE AN OPTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT IF THIS CONFLICT AS
ENOUGH IT AS BEEN DONE. TO OUT
TO MERIT -- PUBLIC USE.
THAN AT THIS BILLS GO ALLOW THAT
TO HAPPEN SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TO THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
MISS RUBIO SECOND BY MISTER
GLORIA.
PLEASE CALL ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW NO BIGELOW NO CHOI KNOWN
CHOI KNOWN.
TO FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I FIVE OKAY WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON I'M GOING TO
ASK -- I'LL MAKE A MOTION TO
MOVE ITEM TO WHICH WAS SENATE
BILL EIGHT THE STATE PARKS OFFER
BEACHES SMOKING BAN IS OUR
SECOND.
SECOND I MISS RUBIO.
US FOR A ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CHOI -- CHOI AYE CHU
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE.
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD HI. SIX THANK YOU LEAVE
THAT OPEN WE HAVE TWO PRESENTERS
HERE WE HAVE THIS RIVAS.
AND MR DOT.
YOU GUYS YOU FLIP A COIN
SYLLABLES FIRST.
MISTER MISS I THINK WAS RIVAS IS
FIRST.
I BELIEVE -- I THINK BECAUSE
ETIQUETTE IS TO LET LADIES GO
FIRST YEAH.
THANK I THINK.
I THINK IT'S AN FOLLOWERS AND
BUT WE'LL BE.
RIGHT WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE AJ ARE EIGHTEEN
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
TO ENACT HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN NO WAIT THAT WAS
INTRODUCED BY CONGRESSMAN ADAM
SCHIFF EARLIER THIS YEAR TO ADD
A HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
ACRES OF THE RIM OF THE VALLEY
CORRIDOR. TO THE SANTA MONICA
NATIONAL RECREATION AREA.
IN MOST AIR QUALITY REPORTS LOS
ANGELES CONTINUOUSLY RANKS AS
ONE OF THE CITIES WITH THE WORST
AIR QUALITY POOR AIR QUALITY IS
PARTICULARLY FELT BY LOW INCOME
ANGELINOS OF COLOR.
THIS IS REFLECTED IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT A
PREDOMINANTLY LATINO DISTRICT
THAT HAS SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY AND LA COUNTY.
WHILE IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED THAT
INCREASING GREEN SPACES
DECREASES DECREASES POLLUTANTS
IN THE AIR LOS ANGELES HAS BEEN
FOUND TO BE SEVERELY DEFICIENT
IN ACCESS TO THESE GREEN SPACES.
OB SO BY SUPPORTING THIS THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WE'RE NOT
ONLY PROTECTING OUR LANDSCAPES
OF BUT ALSO -- YOU KNOW THE
ABUNDANT FLORA AND FAUNA THAT
THIS AREA THE RIM OF THE VALLEY
CORRIDOR -- WILL ALSO PROTECT
THESE LANDS -- FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS YOU KNOW THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EYEBALLS THANK YOU ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MR WARNER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ANYONE ELSE SEEN.
NO ONE ANYONE.
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
HOW ONE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
IS OUR MOTION?
THE MOTION WAS GLORIA TAKEN BY
MS GARCIA [inaudible]
QUESTIONS PLEASE.
JUST OUT OF JUST HAD A CONCERNED
AND AND IT'S KIND OF BEEN A
LITTLE THING I'VE BEEN
CONTINUALLY BRINGING UP.
OUR PARKS HAVE A TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUS.
AMOUNT OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND IS RECOGNIZED AT THE
NATIONAL PARKS IN THIS CASE.
THE CHAIR AND I'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS AT LEAST FOR OUR STATE
PARKS.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO STEP
UP TO THE PLATEIS THIS AS THE
STATE.
SHOULD WITH ITS BUDGET.
TO HELP THE ALL THOSE DEFERRED
ACTIONS THE NATIONAL PARK IS
ACTUALLY WAITING ON HIS ACTION
AND IS STATED.
THAT THEY OPPOSE IT.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TAKING
ON MORE OF THE MAYOR OF THIS AND
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS JUST
[inaudible]
TREMENDOUS SO.
HOW CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
BY ADDING MORE?
ACREAGE TO AN OVERBURDENED
[inaudible]
PARK ALREADY -- YEAH THOUGH I
THINK THAT'S A GREAT CONSIDER
THE A GREAT QUESTION AND CONCERN --
YOU KNOW AND SOMETIMES WE DON'T
THINK ABOUT MAINTENANCE AND LIKE
YOU SAID OUR OUR NATIONAL PARKS
ARE OVERBURDENED BUT I THINK
THAT.
IN THE FUTURE THAT WE YOU KNOW
AS PART OF THIS RESOLUTION THAT
WE SHOULD BE WORKING ON A PLAN --
FOR MAINTENANCE OF THAT AREA I
THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT -- TO
PUT TO ADD GREEN SPACE TO THIS
AREA THAT IT'S SORELY NEEDS YOU
KNOW THIS IN LOS ANGELES WHICH
INCLUDES MY DISTRICT -- AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M
WILLING TO WORK ON WITH THE GUT
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
OUR STATE PARKS ON YES WHAT AND
I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND JUST SO I KEEP IT FRESH IN
EVERYONE'S MIND -- YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE HOW MANY ACRES
MAKE UP THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY O'DONNELL
NUMBER STATE WILL STAY AWHILE NO
I DON'T TWO HUNDRED AND ONE
MILLION ACRES.
AND OF THAT HUNDRED AND ONE HOW
MANY ARE ACTUALLY ALREADY AND
PARKS AND PRESERVED.
I DON'T KNOW YEAH PLEASE TELL ME
OVER FIFTY THREE MILLION.
AND OF THE REMAINING BALANCE
THAT'S ON THE BOOKS WE USE LESS
THAN ONE FIFTH. FOUR PEOPLE
CURRENTLY IN THE STATE.
WE HAVE GREEN SPACE AND IT'S NOT
IN MY DISTRICT IN MY AREA AT
THIS IT ROOM OF THE VALLEY WOULD
ADD GREEN SPACE TO AN URBAN AREA.
THE HAS BEEN IGNORED THAT HAS
POOR AIR QUALITY AND VERY LITTLE
GREEN SPACE -- SO THAT'S WHAT I
THAT'S WHY I'M PRESENTING THIS.
RESOLUTION I GET THAT I JUST
LIKE TO KEEP.
FRESH IN EVERYONE'S MIND WE HAVE
A TON TO PRESERVE OUR THE
PROBLEM IS WE DIDN'T MAYBE
NECESSARILY.
COULD A PARKED EVERYWHERE THAT
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN FACT IN
MANY CASES LANDS WERE ACQUIRED
THAT WERE SLATED FOR PARKS IN
THE STATE.
GO BACK AND CHECK THE HISTORY
YOU'LL FIND THAT.
WE TOOK IT AWAY FROM THE PARKS
AND WE PUT HOUSES ON IT.
WE COVERED OVER THAT GREEN SPACE
THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED.
TO HAVE.
AND AND AND SAUDI I I AGREE WITH
YOU.
YET IN THE CONTEXT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE.
SO HAVING SAID THAT THE GETS
BACK TO THE POINT HOW DO WE
MANAGE OURSELVES IN THE FUTURE
BECAUSE WE'VE MADE THE MISTAKES
WE KNOW ABOUT THE MISTAKES.
HOW DO WE FIX THAT AND AT THE
SAME TIME COMPENSATE FOR THE
FACT THAT?
WE'RE NOT TAKING CARE OF WHAT WE
DO HAVE.
SO I'M JUST WHAT KIND OF MAKING
A WILL IT IS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS HERE
I DON'T KNOW THAT CAN SUPPORT IT
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE DEFERRED.
MAINTENANCE ISSUE AND AND THE
FACT THAT THE PARTS OF WAY DâN.
BUT I AGREE WITH YOU THERE'S
MORE SPACE THAT'S NEEDED FOR
CERTAIN AREAS AND OTHER AREAS
WHICH IS FINE.
BUT ONE THING IS REALLY MISSING.
FUNDING TO TAKE CARE OF WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO PUT INTO A PARK.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO WORK ON AS A COMMITTEE
HERE.
I THINK YOUR POINTS ARE WELL
TAKEN.
YEAH I AGREE WITH YOU THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING UP THOSE POINTS AND
I THINK THEY'RE THEY'RE VALID
POINTS TO A YOU KNOW IT IN
ADDITION TO ADDING SPACE TO OUR
PARKS. TO THINKING ABOUT THE
MAINTENANCE RIGHT BECAUSE THEN
THAT'S THE NEXT STEP THAT'S WHEN --
WE HEAR FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING
MAINTAINED AND OUR END BUT I
THINK THIS IS THE FIRST STEP --
AND I YOU KNOW I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE ELECTED IN MY
AREA -- TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WE'RE WORKING ON A MAINTENANCE
PLAN AND FOR A SPECIAL FUNDING I
MEAN THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WE COME TO
DO A MOTION A SECOND SOME MEMBER
A REQUEST THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD FOR ADVOCATING FOR
YOUR DISTRICT.
AND FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AS WE ALL.
HAVE -- EXPRESSED HERE.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN HOW
IMPORTANT THE OPEN SPACES ARE --
TO OUR COMMUNITIES THE SHOW
BOXES AND ALSO HOW THE BECOME
ECONOMIC ENGINE DRIVERS RIGHT
THAT THEY THEY DO.
BRING PEOPLE IT SPENDING VISIT
THAN GERMANY OUR HELP CONTRIBUTE
TO WHAT COULD BE AN OVERALL PLAN.
FOR POTENTIAL FUTURE MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS OF THESE BIKES UP
THANK YOU AGAIN IN THE THANK YOU
YOU HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED EDUARDO
GARCIA HI GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE.
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I SIXTY ONE ALRIGHT WE
WILL TAKE THAT UP WITH YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
WHO [inaudible]
HELLO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
FOUR ESPY SIXTY TWO DODD IS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER.
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA HI
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN ICE CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE BLANCA RUBIO THE ****
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD HI.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
ALSO PROGRAMS AREN'T.
SENATE US.
TO BUILD NICE MEANS COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING THANK CHAIRMAN AND
AND MEMBERS ARE PRESENTING SB
NINETEEN PERTAINING TO STREAM
GAGES.
SB NINETEEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
DEVELOP A PLAN. TO DEPLOY A
NETWORK OF STREAM GAUGES
INCLUDING A DETERMINATION OF
FUNDING NEEDS AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR REACTIVATING EXISTING STREAM
GAGES.
DURING OUR FIVE YEAR DROUGHT
MANAGING OUR WATER SUPPLY WAS
GROWING MORE CRITICAL IN
DIFFICULT DUE TO GAPS IN STATE
AND REGIONAL WATER DATA IN
MOTION AND A SECOND CENTER DOT
PLEASE PROCEED.
UNDER THE THEORY THAT YOU CAN'T
MANAGE WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW I
AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE
THE OPEN AND TRANSPARENT DATA
WATERGATE ACT.
PURSUANT TO THE ACT D. W. ARE
THE WATER BOARD OTHERS ARE
BUILDING AT A FEDERATED DATA
PLATFORM.
THEY BRING TOGETHER A BROAD
RANGE OF WATER RELATED DATA SETS
THAT MEANT THAT WATER MANAGERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS.
CAN USE TO MAKE SCIENCE BASED
WATER POLICY -- DECISIONS THIS
IS UNDER CONSTRUCTION AT THIS
TIME. 86% OF THE STATE'S
SIGNIFICANT STREAMS ARE POORLY
GATES RESTORING THE STREAM GAGES
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF A
STATEWIDE WATER.
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY THERE'S A
LOT OF SUPPORT OPPOSITION SB
NINETEEN AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES PLACE GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LIZ FORCE BURKE AND I'M
THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WE
ARE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT SENATE
BILL.
NINETEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
PUBLISHED ANALYSIS OF CALIFORNIA
STREAM GAUGES AND DISCOVER THAT
POORLY GAUGE STREAMS FAR OUT
NUMBER WHILE GATES TRIMS.
AND ONLY HALF OF OUR GAUGING THE
STATE ARE ACTIVE.
STREAM GAGES PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
WATER GAPS IN THE STREAM GAUGE
NETWORK MAKE IT DIFFICULT
UNDERSTAND STREAMFLOW CONDITIONS.
I MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO ENSURE
THE BOTH PEOPLE AND NATURE ARE
GETTING WATER WHERE AND WHEN
THEY NEED IT.
AN INFECTIVE STREAM GAUGE
NETWORK WILL HELP SUPPORT
INFORMED DECISION MAKING FOR
WATER MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING UNDERSTAND HOW WE
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE CAN IMPROVE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
AND THE IMPACTS OF DROUGHTS
FLOODS AND EVEN WILD FIRES THAT
HAVE ON OUR STREAMS OF STONES.
SB NINETEEN WOULD HELP IDENTIFY
WATERSHED THE HAVE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT GAPS WERE INACTIVE
GAUGES EXIST AND PRIORITIZE
FUNDING TO DEPLOY GAUGES BASED
UPON THE GAPS IN THE SYSTEM
IMPROVING OUR DATA TO MANAGE
WATER IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF SNOW MORE
WATER WERE THE WHOLESALE WATER
SUPPLIER FOR CINEMA COUNTY -- WE
ACTUALLY GET TO ENJOY SOMETHING
OF A NETWORK OF STREAM GAUGES WE
HAVE SOME IN THE RUSSIAN RIVER
WATERSHED SYSTEM -- WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT ABOUT THESE GAUGES THE
REAL TIME DATA THAT WE GET TO TO
VIEW AN OBSERVER THROUGH THESE
GAUGES.
WE USE THIS DATA. TO TRACK A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT -- A
REQUIREMENTS AS RELATES TO FLOWS
COMPLIANCE FOR MINIMUMS OF THEIR
BIOLOGICAL OPINION FOR FISH
HABITAT WATER SUPPLY FLOWS
RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN USING IT
MORE TO UNDERSTAND ARE FLEDGED
FLOOD MANAGEMENT EXCUSE ME AND
FLOOD FORECASTING.
AS WE SEE THE FLOWS INCREASE WE
CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE DEBRIS
FLOWS MIGHT BE COMING.
ON THE RUSSIAN RIVER.
AND RECENTLY WE STARTED
PUBLISHING THIS REAL TIME DATA
ON A WEBSITE SO THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN ACTUALLY SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
THAT SAID.
WERE WERE UNDER GAUGED WHERE
WE'D LIKE TO BE -- WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FINANCIAL ASPECT OF THESE
GAUGES WHAT WE REALLY SEE THIS
BILL HELPING OUT IS?
THE DEPLOYMENT OF GAUGES WE
THINK THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE ROLE
FOR THE STATE WE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ARE PICKING UP MORE THE
MAINTENANCE COSTS AND WE THINK
THAT ASPECT OF A LOCAL STATE
FEDERAL.
PARTNERSHIP IS IS WHAT THIS BILL
WILL ACHIEVE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR ABOUT THANK
YOU BOB OTHER -- WITNESSES LOT.
NAME ORGANIZATION [inaudible]
THIS IS.
GOOD MORNING CAROLING ABOVE THE
NAPA COUNTY PART OF SUPERVISORS
IS PART.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HI BABRI BREED GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
ATWATER COALITION AND THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER VALLEY FLOOD
CONTROL ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MR CHEN MEMBERS PAT RENT THERE
AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIST IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
DO NOT ASK ABOUT THE HAVE THE
CONTRA COSTA WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS JOHN
INSTITUTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER COALITION
IN THE GROUND WATER RESOURCES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ FOR
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ROSIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THEN YOU'RE BLESSED HIDING WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND TODAY CAL THESE
ALLEN SUPPORT.
IT ALSO SIERRA CLUB IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
CERES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILAREPA IN THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALTERNATE
VALLEY WATER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU I KNOW CENTER DOT
SAID THERE WAS NO OPPOSITION SO
I GATHER THERE'S NO ONE UP
RIPPLES IN THE BILL.
HI TECH OFFERS WORK ALL RIGHT.
OKAY JUST THE FACT CHECKING
THAT'S ON THE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
MR BIGELOW THE DOCTOR WOULD.
MR DOT -- YOU HAVE -- THIS VERY
INTRIGUING -- THERE ARE A LOT OF
OLD GAUGES THAT ARE AROUND.
AND THEY ARE BEING USED THEIR
JUST STILL SITTING OUT THERE
SOME OF THE OLD.
OLD STYLE THERE JUST IN OLD
CULVERTS THAT ARE.
COVERED AND I'VE OFTEN WONDERED
WHY WE DON'T UTILIZE THAT
INFORMATION AS BEST WE COULD.
YES THEY WERE IN PLACE -- BUT
NONE THE LESS THE BILL DOES POSE
ANOTHER QUESTION.
IT SAYS THE STREAMS DOES THAT
MEAN ALL STREAMS.
WITHIN HAVE TO BE MONITORED
UNDER YOUR BILL OR WOULD BE JUST
A SELECT ONES THAT ARE BEING
UTILIZED.
CURRENTLY FOR BENEFICIAL
PURPOSES.
THAT WOULD BE MY FIRST QUESTION.
YES SURE I'M HAPPY TO GET TO THE
QUESTIONS OF THE BILL WOULD HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES HELP PRIORITIZE WHERE
WE WOULD DEPLOY GAUGES.
BASED UPON DIFFERENT PRIORITIES
FOR THE STATE.
OKAY SECOND QUESTION THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OF STREAMS AND
WATERWAYS THAT HAVE HAD.
STOCK PONDS PLACED ON AND NOW
THE UNDER PREVIOUS LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
MONITOR -- AND THOSE.
A STREAMS WITH THAT DISBURSEMENT
WATER WHETHER IT'S USED FOR
OTHER BENEFICIAL PURPOSES OR
JUST USE FOR RETENTION OF WATER.
WITH THE FUNDS FOR THOSE TOOLS
THOSE GAUGES BE PART OF THIS.
OUR ACTION AS WELL SO THAT THE
LAND OWNERS TO GET COST RECOVERY
FOR THOSE IMPACTS OF BEEN PLACED
UPON THEM.
BECAUSE YOUR RETORT TO ROUTE YOU
WOULD BE DERIVING STRONG
BENEFICIAL INFORMATION.
AS AN AGENCY.
YEAH I THINK WE'RE THE BILL
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THE ABILITY TO SORT OF DETERMINE
WHAT PRIORITY SHOULD BE MADE SO
YOU WOULD BE SO YOU'D SEE SOME
LATITUDE.
ARE TO BEING ABLE TO WORK WITH
THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE THIS HAS
BECOME QUITE A BURDEN.
UPON A NUMBER OF LANDOWNERS ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THAT WE'VE
HAD -- AND A NUMBER OF
LANDOWNERS IN IN MY DISTRICT
THAT HAVE HAD THAT ISSUE AND I
DON'T KNOW I I I'LL CHECK WITH
STAFF AND DOUBLE CHECK WITH
STAFF ON THAT BAND AND WORK ON
THAT ISSUE OF WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY -- TO DO SOMETHING
MORE SPECIFICALLY IF IT'S
COVERED FANTASTIC IT'S NOT I
JUST DON'T WANT TO SAY A BAGGIE
ON IT WILL.
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT IDEA
RIGHT WELL HAVING HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT I THINK I I THINK I'M
HEARING.
THE LATITUDE IS THERE AND AND
WITH THAT SAID.
ON I'M PLEASED TO HEAR THAT
WOULD BE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR THE DOCTOR.
JUST -- SHOULD THE BILL PASSES
YEAH.
A TEST ON QUESTION OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IN UNDER WAS MOTION BY MRS RUBIO
AND DOCTOR WHAT.
WHICH I CLOSE CENTER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THANK YOU.
REAL COMPANIES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE KALRA.
COLOR I'D LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
MARCO RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
THE MEMBERS HAD ON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND STAFF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
NO WE'VE HAD A COUPLE OF NEW
MEMBERS [inaudible]
STEP IN.
IF WE WANT TO TAKE IT FROM THE
TOP FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
TO SOME OF THE BILL'S WE'VE
TAKEN.
WE'LL START WITH THE ITEM.
ONE AJ ARE.
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED GALLAGHER [inaudible] TO
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I YES [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE SALAS. ONE
NINE TWO ONE SB.
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I COR A KALRA.
KALRA AYE.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I SALAS [inaudible] NINE
TWO ONE SB NINETEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible] ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SB SIXTY TWO DO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER TO PASS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA I LEVINE.
LEVINE I SALAS. TEN TWO ZERO ON
CALL.
SB.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHIU.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN GLAZER
[inaudible]
HI. TWO FIVE TWO I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I KALRA.
KALRA I LEVINE.
LEVINE I SALAS [inaudible]
SEVENTY NINE ON CALL.
AND THAT'S IT
.
H. HERE [inaudible] EIGHTEEN
FIVE STERN FROM THE TOP.
SB. EIGHT TO FIVE SB.
NINETEEN TWO HI. TWO I CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CHIU [inaudible] TWO I SB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE AND I AND
THAT'S IT
.
HELLO DID WAS THERE TO THE YEAH
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
YEAH [inaudible]
SO WITH [inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THE GARDEN [inaudible]
WATER.
PLEASE PROCEED YES SB TWO SIXTY
TWO MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
PROVISIONS RELATING TO
COMMERCIAL FISHING LANDING FEES.
SEA CUCUMBER PERMITS AMERICAL TO
PERMITTING AND THAT THEN JUST
CRAP TRAP RETRIEVAL PROGRAM.
THANKFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WE HAVE SOME EXPERTS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NO
OPPENHEIM WITH THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS EVERY ONCE IN
AWHILE THE LEGISLATURE WILL PASS
THE FISHERIES OMNIBUS BILL THAT
WILL.
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
SUSTAINABLY [inaudible]
AND AND THIRDLY OPERATE
COMMERCIAL FISHERIES FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE PUBLIC IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL HAS A
COUPLE OF IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
THE FISH AND GAME CODE INCLUDING
A PARTICULAR ENABLING GEAR.
LEFT BEHIND AFTER FISHING SEASON
IN THE DONE JUST CRIED FISHERY
TO BE RETRIEVED IF THERE IS AN
EARLIER THAN NORMAL CLOSURE FOR
EXAMPLE THIS.
LAST FISHING SEASON -- AND IN
ADDITION IT WOULD ALLOW THE FEE
STRUCTURE.
RECOVERED FROM COMMERCIAL
FISHING LANDINGS RECEIPTS TO BE
INCREMENTALLY CHANGE ACCORDING
TO THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
RIGHT MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE CONTRACTS ON BEHALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY.
SB TWO SIXTY TWO CONTAINS
NUMEROUS IMPORTANT CHANGES BUT I
THINK WE'RE HERE PRIMARILY IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED CRAB
GEAR EVER TRAVEL PROVISIONS --
THE GEARED RETRIEVAL PROVISION
MODIFICATIONS CONTAINED WITHIN
SB TWO SIXTY TO ENSURE THAT THE
GEAR WHICH PEOPLE CAN OCCUR WHEN
THE FISHERY SE
WELL AS OTHER TIMES TAKE IS
RESTRICTED DUE TO THE RISK OF
MARINE LIFE ENTANGLEMENTS.
AND WE'VE SERVED AS A MEMBER
ALONG OF THE WORKING GROUP SINCE
ITS INCEPTION AND IT'S TRULY
TEAM EFFORT BETWEEN PFT.
PC FFA IN NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
APARTMENT OTHERS SOME EXPECT A
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
I'D JUST AS I THOUGHT IT WOULD
HAPPEN.
THE OTHER EL.
THIS WILL IT.
AND DON.
THANK YOU FOR THE TWO WITNESSES.
THOSE ARE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
RATHER SUPPORT SUPPORT I'M SORRY.
DO YOU RATE THE WRECKAGE ON THE
HALF OF THE PACIFIC -- SHELLFISH
GROW GROWERS ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT WE IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE FEEL THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN.
EXPANDING OUR SUSTAINABLE MAYOR
CULTURE INDUSTRY.
JUST MULLIN FOR THE HOG ISLAND
OYSTER COMPANY FOR THE SAME
REASONS WE SUPPORT AMERICA ULTRA
PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID
GOLDENBERG I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA SEVEN COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA SEA URCHIN COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK FOR ROB ROSS'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SAY A THE FOOD AND
FISHERIES INSTITUTE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THOSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
K. F. C. NO ONE THAT WE HAVE THE
AUTHOR THE BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DO -- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
QUESTION FROM UP HERE WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND. TO MAKE WE
DIDN'T GET A MOTION -- SECOND.
OF THE WORD. TO AT WOULD LIKE TO
SAVINGS NOW AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL.
SOMETHING IS AN AMAZING
PRESENTATIONS -- IN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND SORROWS IN IN IN BEING
PIANO WORKS.
WAS FOR RECORD DOES HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND NATURAL RESOURCES
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW [inaudible]
LAST.
HOLY CRAP HEY SEE THERE YOU GO.
NICE BIGELOW AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
MARCO RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I OKAY LEAVE THAT OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR GRATEFUL --
THAT.
ANALYSTS THOUGH STILL OKAY
PLEASE.
I KNOW I SALAS THAT PERSONS ONCE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SB THREE THIRTEEN PROHIBITS
CIRCUSES IN THE STATE FROM YOU
SEEN ANIMALS WITH LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
RIGHT WELL WITNESSES IS TO BE IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE WE DO WITNESSES.
WHAT ELSE IS IN SUPPORT?
OF A SERVICE OF BELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
THE MOTION SECOND [inaudible]
THERE'S SUPPORT.
WHAT WE HAVE?
I'M.
BEING THAT THE THE AUTHORS ARE
NGUYEN PRESIDENT WE'VE PROCEEDED
TO PRESENT BILLS ON BEHALF OF
OTHERS -- THERE IS A MOTION A
SECOND FOR SENATE BILL -- THREE
THIRTEEN AS IT WHERE WE JUST ASK
FOR WITNESSES TO COME FORWARD.
AND IF THE CENTER WALKS IN
CONSTRICTED THE THE MICROPHONE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO EVERYONE GOOD [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE STRANGEST CENTER FOR ONE
MINUTE OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING.
EVERYONE THANK YOU I'M JUDY MAN
CREW SO FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
WERE A CO SPONSOR.
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING LAWS HAVE
FAILED TO PROTECT ANIMALS IN
CIRCUSES CLYDE THE LION BAKED TO
DEATH IN A CIRCUS BOX CAR
TRAVELING THROUGH THE MOJAVE
DESERT TO FRESNO.
TEMPERATURES SOARED TO ONE
HUNDRED DEGREES BUT THE CIRCUS
DIDN'T BOTHER TO STOP FOR HIM
AND HUNTINGTON PARK AT TIGER WAS
NEARLY DECAPITATED.
AFTER A CIRCUS CRAMMED HER INTO
A CAGE WITH FIVE OTHER CATS
ANIME SEATED ELEPHANT HAD A DROP
DEAD AFTER SHE PERFORMED AT A
CIRCUS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER ELEPHANT WITH THE
CIRCUITS JOYCE HAD DIED JUST
DAYS BEFORE THE GOOD NEWS IS
THERE IS NO CIRCUS IS BASED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT USING ANIMALS WE
NEED TO EVEN THE PLAYING FIELD
WITH THE OUT LIARS.
THE ANIMAL CIRCUSES THE VISIT
OUR STATE HAVE RECORDS OF
HARMING ANIMALS AND ENDANGERING
THE PUBLIC. TWO CUBS DIED AND
FEDERAL INSPECTORS SEIZE THE
THIRD THEY FOUND HIM CONFINED IN
A DOG CARRIER IN THE HOT CAB OF
THE TRUCK.
A US DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
OFFICIAL.
WROTE THAT THE CIRCUS
DEMONSTRATED A SHOCKINGLY
CAVALIER ATTITUDE REGARDING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE ANIMALS.
EXCUSE ME PULLING SHOWS THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT BANNING ANIMALS AND
CIRCUS WE LOOK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR HAVE
THE RALLY I AM THOSE SUPERVISING
VETERINARIAN AT THE PETER
FOUNDATION -- AND I'M ALSO
ADJUNCT FACULTY OF VERMONT LAW
SCHOOL WHERE I CO TEACH ANIMAL
WELFARE LAW.
I'M I WORK PRIMARILY FOCUSES ON
EXPOSING AND PUTTING AN END TO
THE SUFFERING THAT CAP TO WILD
ANIMALS AND DOOR AND CIRCUSES
ANOTHER TRAVELING ACTS -- THE
INSULTS TO ANIMAL WELFARE AND
SERVICES ARE THERE NUMEROUS
THEIR FREQUENT AND THEY ARE
EXTREME -- INTENSIVE CONFINEMENT
FOR EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME
EXPOSURE TO STRESSFUL AN
UNFAMILIAR ENVIRONMENTS AND
ABUSIVE TRAINING TECHNIQUES ALL
MAKE THE CIRCUS A MISERABLE
PLACE FOR ANIMALS.
THESE ANIMALS DON'T PERFORM
TRICKS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DO
SO THEY DO SO BECAUSE THEY'RE
TERRIFIED OF THE CONSEQUENCES IF
THEY DO NOT PERFORM.
AND THIS IS PETER HAS DOCUMENTED
REPEATEDLY THE ANIMALS IN THE
CIRCUS HAVE BEEN TAUGHT THROUGH
VICIOUS BEATINGS BEHIND THE
SCENES.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THEM IF THEY
DO NOT -- BANG -- AND THEY SPEND
MUCH OF THEIR LIVES EVEN DAYS ON
AND LANGUISHING IN DARK BARREN
TRAILERS SO AS A RESULT OF THIS
TREATMENT ANIMALS CAN LASH OUT
IN FRUSTRATION.
MANY OF THEM HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN IMPLICATED IN HUMAN INJURIES
AND EVEN IN HUMAN DEATHS -- THE
I'VE SEEN THE FIRST HAND THE
TOTAL FAILURE OF OUR EXISTING
LAWS TO PROTECT THESE ANIMALS
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
AND THAT THAT'S BOTH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND CALIFORNIA'S
PERMITTING PROCESSES WHICH
FAILED TO PROMOTE GOOD ANIMAL
WELFARE SO PLEASE VOTE YES ON
ANYTHING ON THE ONE THAT'S GOOD
THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE --
COME FOR STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
A GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR KAREN
LÏNG UP OF THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE ASSOCIATION AND
THE HUMANE SOCIETY TONIGHT
STATES BUT THAT'S PART THANK YOU.
HI I'M LESLIE MACKAY WITH ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKS.
I AM SAID THE A DIAMOND FROM ELK
GROVE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I'M NATALIE GRAHAM A TEACHER I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF HUNDREDS
OF CHILDREN PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I'M ERIN O'BRIEN I'M A CONCERNED
CITIZEN VOTER AN EDUCATOR AND I
URGE OUR STRONG SUPPORT -- I'M
ALISA FRY I'M A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT AND A AM IN FULL SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DEBBIE CASEY SACRAMENTO RESIDENT
IN SUPPORT.
WHICH ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FRANK MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE ZOO LOGICAL SO
SHE'S TO OF AMERICA IN ITS
HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS AFFILIATES.
AND THE MODERATES TO A LOGICAL
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE DOYLE WITH THE
PERFORMING ANIMAL WELFARE
SOCIETY IN SAN ANDREAS AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE BIG CATS
CENTURY ALLIANCE AND ALSO A
COALITION OF TWENTY ANIMAL
PROTECTION ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE BILL DOES HAVE A
TO PASS RECOMMENDATION WITH
AMENDMENTS IF ACCEPTED BY THE
AUTHOR DO A MOTION A SECOND.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
OKAY SEE NO ONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
THE MEASURE.
YES.
YEAH FOR THE AUTHORED JUST TOOK
A QUESTION AS AS WE SEE THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD THERE
THERE'S A CONCERN I SEE YOU'VE
TAKEN ON AN AMENDMENT.
DEALING WITH THE RODEOS BUT IT
DOES LAY THE GROUNDWORK AND
STILL THE OPEN FOUNDATION WHAT
HAPPENS TO OUR ZOOS IN THE
FUTURE ARE THEY GOING TO BE A
ACTED.
ARE IMPACTED BY THIS.
INCREMENTAL STEPPING ON WOULD WE
SEE FOUR H. AND FFA SHOWS WERE
LIVESTOCK ISSUES UTILIZED
POTENTIALLY.
A COULD WE BE LOOKING AT DOG
SHOWS DO YOU SEE THIS AS JUST
ONE STEP IN THE PROGRESSION OF A
CHANGING.
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE LOVE AND
ENJOY THE SHOW?
WHICH IS SHOWING ANIMALS OR
HAVING RODEOS INSIDE.
THANK YOU -- IF I KNEW THE
FUTURE I WOULDN'T BE HERE
[inaudible]
BUT YEAH.
YOU KNOW MY BEST GUESSES.
THE THE WORLD CHANGES AND AND
THE WORLD IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO CHANGE.
DO I KNOW WHAT DIRECTION NO I
DON'T.
THIS BILL IS IS NARROWLY FOCUSED
ON ON A SPECIFIC TYPE OF ANIMAL
IN A SPECIFIC VENUE -- AS AS
YOU'VE SEEN -- THE ADVOCATES OF
THIS BILL COME FORWARD THEY
REPRESENT SUSE THEY'VE
REPRESENTS A LOGICAL SITE IS A
REPRESENT -- PEOPLE WHO CARE FOR
ANIMALS IN EVERY MANNER.
AND SO -- THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL.
I HOPE -- YOU'LL YOU'LL YOU'LL
AGREE WITH ME THAT IT'S TIME TO
MOVE FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA IN
THIS AREA.
AND AND AND YOU KNOW I WOULD I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OF IT THE TIME HAS COME TO SEE
THE THE END OF OF EXOTIC.
AND WILD ANIMALS BEATING BEING
TREATED IN THIS MANNER AND THAT
IS REALLY WHAT OUR FOCUS IS
ABOUT IN THIS BILL [inaudible]
SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WHILE THE MOTION THE
SECOND DO INCLUDE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED BY.
COMMITTEE I THINK THAT YOU
ACCEPTED BILLS.
I GUESS OR I SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR IS IT
MORE SECOND BROKE UP PLEASE.
THE MOST I CAN JUST YES PLEASE
YOU I I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENT THANKS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR SEVEN
AND AND HELP IN THE ADVANCES
BECAUSE THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF. FOR
HELP IN THIS TO MAKE THIS A
BETTER BILL RIGHT [inaudible]
BROKE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO HELLO.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING CHIU. TWO I
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
WOULD I WOULD I TWO ONE FOUR I
WILL BE TO OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
[inaudible]
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THIS IS OUR OF FINAL BILL ON THE
AGENDA.
YOU DO HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- SENATOR.
SOME OF THE MOTION BY MISS RUBIO.
SECOND BY MS GARCIA DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
VERY BRIEFLY I HAVE NO NOTES --
BECAUSE THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS BILL.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN I FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS WITH RESPECT.
TO OUR CONSERVATION IS A WAY OF
LIFE A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO IN
THE FACE OF THE DROUGHTS.
BY THE GOVERNOR BROWN -- ISSUED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER A
DRAMATICALLY REDUCING THE USE OF
WATER IN CALIFORNIA.
HE HAD A TRAILER BILL A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO THAT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
BETTER THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT BETWEEN
BOTH HOUSES ENGAGE IN THE
PROCESS IS APPROPRIATE.
AND SO IS A TEAM OF MEASURES A
MEASURE BY SENATOR FRIEDMAN.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN MAYBE
CENTER FROM DAY -- AND MYSELF TO
BASICALLY MAKE CONSERVATION IS A
WAY OF LIFE THIS MEASURE
CORRECTS.
A A CHALLENGE THAT WAS FACED IN
TERMS OF INTERPRETING WHAT THAT
MEANT IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
CONSERVATION EFFORTS ARE DO YOU
LOOK AT IT AGENCY TOE IN
TOTALITY OF ITS RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL.
AGRICULTURE OF THE USE IN TERMS
OF ITS REDUCTION OR DO YOU LOOK
AT EACH HOUSE WE RECEIVED SOME
CRITICISMS ALONG THE WAY THAT
PEOPLE SAID OH MY GOD I CAN'T
FLUSH MY TOILET TAKE A SHOWER IN
THE SAME DAY.
BECAUSE OF THIS THAT WASN'T THE
INTENT WERE CLARIFYING THAT WITH
THIS MEASURE ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THEY HAVE WHAT'S AHEAD WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT THIS MEASURE --
AS SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
HERTZBERG NOTED -- THERE WAS A
HERCULEAN EFFORT TO ADVANCE
GROUNDBREAKING LEGISLATION TO
MAKE CONSERVATION A WAY OF LIFE
WE WERE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
FINAL PACKAGE INCLUDING SB SIX
OH SIX AND A. B. -- SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT URBAN WATER
SUPPLIERS WILL NOT BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING IN URBAN
WATER OBJECTIVE USE OBJECTIVE
MADE UP OF FOUR COMPONENTS
INDOOR USE OUTDOOR USE.
SEE I DEDICATED YOUR GIPSON
METERS AND WATER LOSS.
THE TOTALS OF EACH COMPONENT
WILL BE ADDED UP TO ESTABLISH A
CUMULATIVE OBJECTIVE FOR EACH
SUPPLIER THIS APPROACH WE FEEL
PROVIDES EACH WATER SUPPLIER THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE WHICH
AREAS THEY WILL FOCUS ON BASED
WHAT BASED ON WHAT IS BEST FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER IN TWENTY FIFTEEN PRIOR
TO THE PASSAGE OF THE CUT
CONSERVATION BILLS SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE DIRECTED D. W. ARE IN THE
WATER BOARD TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS RELATED TO WATER
LOSS.
INCLUDING THE ADOPTION OF
VOLUMETRIC PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
BY TWENTY TWENTY WHEN THE STATE
BOARD ADOPTS THESE REGULATIONS
WATER LOSS WILL BECOME
ENFORCEABLE -- AS A STANDALONE
TARGET UNLIKE ANY OTHER.
ELEMENT IN THE OBJECTIVE.
THIS MEANS THAT IF A WATER
SUPPLIER MEETS THEIR OBJECTIVE
BUT CHOOSES TO FOCUS ON
REDUCTIONS IN OUR WATER USE AND
DOES NOT MEET THEIR WATER LOSS
TARGET.
THEY WOULD FACE AN ENFORCEMENT
ACTION UNDER THE WATER LOSS
REGULATIONS BUT IF SOME REASON
AN AGENCY DOES NOT MEET THEIR
OBJECTIVE BECAUSE THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY MEETING THE WATER
LOSS STANDARD THE SUPPLIER COULD
FACE TWO SIMULTANEOUS
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS WERE ONE
VIOLATION.
OF LET ME BE CLEAR WATER
SUPPLIERS ARE COMMITTED TO WATER
LOSS AND WE WANT TO MEET THE
OBJECTIVES THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
THE LEGISLATION.
YOU KNOW AND ACTIVELY REDUCE
WATER LOSS IT MAKES FINANCIAL
AND OPERATIONAL SENSE TO DO SO.
I'M WE FEEL WATER LOSS IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT IN THE
OBJECTIVE AND THE CAPTURES A
SYSTEMS VARIOUS WATER USES BUT
WE DON'T FEEL IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR WATER SYSTEMS TO FACE TO
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS FOR THE SAME
VIOLATION.
WE BELIEVE SB ONE THIRTY FOUR IS
A COMMONSENSE MEASURING
COMPLIMENTS THE EFFORTS OF WATER
SUPPLIERS BY PROVIDING CLARITY
THAT IF A WATER SYSTEM EXCEEDS
THEIR WATER LOSS PERFORMANCE
STANDARD.
AND IT RESULTS IN AN X. EVEN
SERVE THE URBAN YOU SUBJECTIVE
THAT SYSTEM WILL ONLY FACE AND
FOR SOME ACTION UNDER THE WATER
LOSS STANDARDS AND NOT THE
CONSERVATION STATUTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
BRIEFLY I TURN MEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE
WERE PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED SB.
ONE THIRTY FOUR I WE BELIEVE
THAT THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE WE
CAN EXISTING LAW BY MAKING WATER
LOSS PERFORMANCE STANDARDS
UNENFORCEABLE BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO BRING.
A SUPPORTERS THE OPPONENTS AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TOGETHER TO
CRAFT A COMPROMISE THAT IS BOTH
FAIR AND BALANCED I'M AND WITH
THAT WE ARE NOW IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS -- WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JULIE HOLE WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL BUT WE JUST WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHORS OFFICE THE SPONSOR
AND THEN OTHERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN THE BILL FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US ON
THE SPECIFIC.
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THANK YOU.
PRINT ALSO SERICA CALIFORNIA WE
WANNA ATTRIBUTE OUR COMMENTS TO
THAT OF IN OUR DC WE ORIGINALLY
OPPOSED BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S MOMENTS IN.
THE FORD WORKING WITH HIM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- THOSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE
MEASURE PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
HIS -- DO IT FROM HERE IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH A CHAIR BUT READ.
ON BEHALF OF READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH THE WATER
DISTRICTS ARE LISTED ON THE
ANALYSIS IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE AT THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF
WERE IN OUR DC WAS WE SUPPORTED
THE BILL AS IT WAS INTRODUCED
AND AND NOW FIND OURSELVES IN
OPPOSITION WE APPRECIATE THE
COMPROMISE WITH RESPECT TO
ENFORCEMENT.
BUT IT DOESN'T DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE TO MEET THE
WATER LOSS STANDARD SEPARATE AND
APART FROM.
THE A COMPROMISE LIST OF
COMPONENTS THAT MAKE UP THE
WATER -- USE OBJECTIVE WE THINK
THE CLEANER UP PLACE WOULD BE TO
JUST PUT THE WATER LOSS STANDARD
IN THE URBAN WATER USE OBJECTIVE
AND NOT HAVE IT BE A SEPARATE
THE STANDARD THAT'S WHY THEY
REMAIN OPPOSED THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH A MOTION SECOND
FOR ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SAY NO.
ONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT'S A NON THE CENTER WHICH LED
TO SPELLS ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AS A TO PASS UP PLEASE QUESTION
I'M SORRY.
SENATOR JUST A YOU JUST HEARD
THAT LAST LITTLE CLOSER FROM --
MISTER REED -- IS THERE ANY WAY
TO MAYBE FIND SOME CLARITY.
THE KIND OF DANCING WITH THAT
BALANCE OF OF THE LANGUAGE THERE.
AS HE WAS TALKING ABOUT IS.
MAYBE TO THE SPONSOR THE LOS
ALSO GO BACK BUT BUT THE THE TH
A MY MY THINKING IS THAT THAT.
THEY JUST DON'T READ AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE HERE HOWEVER I DID
TRY.
TO MEET THAT STANDARD I DID TRY
TO ACHIEVE THAT OBJECTIVE IN THE
PROCESS AND BE HAPPY TO CIRCLE
BACK WITH BUT I THINK WE'VE
ACHIEVED THE OBJECTIVE.
AND TO CLARIFY THE POSITION.
YEAH AND I THINK THAT THE ISSUE
IS THE FACT THAT -- THE WATER
LOSS REGULATIONS PREDATED THE
CONSERVATION STATUTES SO THERE'S
AN EXISTING PROCESS IN PLACE
UNDER SB.
FIVE FIVE FIVE SO THAT'S WHY WE
WORK ON THE COMPROMISE WITH THE
SENATOR AND THE OPPOSITION YEAH
WELL I I FOUND MYSELF IN A
PRECARIOUS POSITION I I ACTUALLY
LIKE WHAT YOU'VE DONE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE IF OU CAN
WORK SOMETHING OUT SO IF YOU CAN
DO THAT AWESOME OF COURSE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY -- BUT
I I I THINK YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF
GOOD WORK HERE TRYING.
TO WE GOT TOO MANY EXAMPLES I
THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF OTHER
EXAMPLES FOR WITH LAYERED.
COMPONENTS LIKE THIS AND WE
MULTIPLE TIMES FOR JUST DOING
ONE ACTION SO.
THANK GOD TO IT THOUGH.
THE THIS IS BEEN A THIS PROCESS
TOOK OVER A YEAR OF JUST
EXTENSIVE MEETINGS THE WATER
WILL YOU KNOW HOW HARD IT IS. TO
TO REACH AGREEMENTS THAT RESPECT
ON CONSERVATION IN PARTICULAR SO
IS ONE SMALL PIECE OF A GIGANTIC
A ENDEAVOR OF A CHANGING AND
REALLY PUTTING IN INTO A
THOUGHTFUL AND THE AND FAR
REACHING CONSERVATION STANDARDS
WHICH REALLY HAVE BROAD ALMOST
EVERYBODY TO THE TABLE.
YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THAT
BROKE UP PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
HELLO I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
I FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
I KALRA.
KALRA HIGH LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
WOULD I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MITCHELL THANK
YOU SENATOR WE WILL -- HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES WILL
START AT THE TOP -- MA'AM
SECRETARY WILL.
ALL THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AJ ARE
[inaudible]
EIGHTEEN GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS I IT'S ELEVEN TO ONE SB
EIGHT GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS NO [inaudible] TEN TO SB
NINETEEN GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS I TWELVE TWO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE. TWELVE WAY.
YEAH [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I IT'S THIRTEEN ZERO
SB ONE THIRTY FOUR GALLAGHER AYE
GALLAGHER AYE [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN. TWELVE TWO ZERO SB TWO
SIXTY TWO GALLAGHER [inaudible]
A CHOIR.
GALLAGHER I SALAS.
SALAS I TWELVE TWO ZERO SB.
THREE THIRTEEN GLORIA HI.
GLORIA I IT'S NINE TWO ONE SALAS
KNOWN. NINE TWO TWO SB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER NO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
SALAS NOW.
IT'S NINE TO FOUR STARTING FROM
THE TOP AGAIN.
AJ ARE EIGHTEEN GALLAGHER.
NOT VOTING GALLAGHER NOT QUOTING.
SB EIGHT GALLAGHER -- NO
GALLAGHER NOW. 1-023- SB
NINETEEN GALLAGHER -- GALLAGHER
I THIRTEEN CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY THE
TEN SIXTY I DO HAVE.
NEWMAN ON THE THIRTEENTH BAKER
.
TO OKAY MEETING JR